tu crois pourquoi tu fais ça en fait ça
sert à quoi en fait voir un mec à voir
non mais que tu connais pas la mairie
comme cela s'est passé 40 ans bout d'un
mois je suis pas tu t'attaches justement
j'ai 40 ans mais justement
donc ta maman va se marier dans quelques
semaines j'aime venir là je connais ni
d'eve ni d'adam
[Musique]
mais moi cette expérience vraiment la
faire avec toi parce que je la partage
avec toi
parce que
tuer la personne qui est le plus
important dans la vie et ça tu le sais
ça
[Musique]
moi je l'équipe les deux gars
aujourd'hui franchement ça sent le fake
à plein nez on l'a vu plein de fois
cette séquence des profs qui sont contre
le fait qu'il fasse l'émission c'est
tout est faux dans cette émission je
déteste il désacralise complètement
mariage sert qu'à l'heure où il ya de
moins en moins de mariages
vous avez conscience de votre tête et il
ya de moins en moins de deux mariages
ont dit voilà bat marié vous pour
rigoler c'est juste pour la télé tu sais
faire c'est n'importe quoi et attention
ne vous trompez pas ils font pas ça pour
trouver l'amour ils font ça pour être
connu et pour faire de la télé est
relancé mais oui il y en a plein qui
vont faire les anges derrière c'est déjà
arrivé fait nulle part mais regarde vous
n'y croyez plaint pas du tout bas
regardez l'histoire c'est maintenant
c'est une bonne émission préférée je
suis très déçu des scores aux qualités
de vélib c'est une émission que j'adore
c'est un divertissement comme un autre
après le fait qu'ils se marient je pense
que c'est propre à chacun c'est eux qui
le destine donc on n'est pas là pour les
juger
après quand tu dis que c'est truqué
j'aimerais que tu sois comme satiné que
tu nous amènes des preuves comme pour
the voice
parce que dire qu'un truc c'est truqué
sans preuve moi ça marche pas je dirais
que c'est truqué je sais pas mais
division alors que ça sent le monde
comme par hasard à chaque foyer à la
petite séquence avec les proches qui
sont pas content là on voit bien qu'elle
en fait des caisses les normes et les
fruits et qu'on parle de trucage merci
aux nanas qui se réveille c'est verdez
mais d'abord c'est un casting de télé
réalité vous aviez hier une mère et sa
fille caricatural yannick yannick qui
est passé dans ninja warriors comme par
hasard le gars y passe dans nigeria il
veut se marier au premier regard
vous aurez bientôt des jumeaux en fait
ils vont chercher des castings pour
créer le buzz ya aucune réalité
effectivement comme ils peuvent divorcer
très facilement un mois après c'est des
gens qui veulent tout simplement faire
de la télé alors et c'est pas tout le
comportement dadis a fait énormément
réagir surtout moment des essayages de
la robe de mariée
la jeune femme a eu des mots très durs
envers sa maman regardez cécile a réussi
à convaincre sa fille de l'accompagner
aux essayages de sa robe de mariée
en espérant que ce moment si symbolique
agissent comme un déclic sur un lissage
ma fille tu n'y vas pas d'ego
moi je trouve que ça a fait bouger un
peu et beaucoup
enfin 2 3 kilos en moins ça serait pas
de refus quoi
régime c'est pour son bien quoi pour pas
que son futur mari disait
genre je dis ça pour qu'elle soit
vraiment parfait alors c'est vrai
qu'elle a beaucoup qui ont rigolé un sur
ces séquences willy bernard montiel oui
et non c'est un peu choquant après
l'essayer notre robe elle a dit pareil
c'est trop gros soit là que tu maigri et
tout ça c'est pas gentil en plus cette
petite anissa les mignonne comme tout
devrait soutenir sa mère qui est belle
même si l teur haletante cette aventure
qui est un peu trucs et si on veut
savoir la soutenir et qui savaient pas
gentil non il ya des analyses médias
quand même c'est quand même quelqu'un